it's a new week and that means it's time
for new releases but this week is a
special week because this week we get
fallout 4 that's right this week you
deep dive into the wasteland with
hundreds of locations characters and
quests join multiple factions vying over
power or just go solo you can collect
upgrading craft weapons or just punch
death calls into submission while using
that famous vault-tec assisted targeting
system and of course make the character
of your dreams with the special
character system you could be a strong
armored soldier or charismatic smooth
talker or my personal favorite all luck
guy this nuke drops on the 10th but
don't leave yet we still have other
amazing games that have the guts to
release on the same week Xbox owners get
their hands on rise of the Tomb Raider
join in on lara's obsession with finding
the truth behind myths from around the
world rides the tomb raider follows lara
croft as she searches Siberia and the
ancient city of cash which she thinks
holds some truth about immortality gonna
need that immortality because a lot of
people are trying to kill her she's
going up to survive against those jerks
a bunch of animals and the environment
to read those tombs is coming out the
same day folks november 10th god help us
all but wait there's more starcraft 2
legacy of the void is coming out on the
same day this is a standalone expansion
pack to starcraft two wings of liberty
it's basically the third movie in the
starcraft 2 trilogy and anyone who
started it is going to want to finish it
the expansion includes additional units
and multiplayer changes from hearts of
the swarm as well as a continuing
campaign following the Protoss species
this also comes out on the 10th choose
wisely other gaming options to consider
if for whatever reason you are legally
insane there's football manager 2016
coming out on pc mac and linux this
friday all the kiddies in the family
will enjoy Animal Crossing amiibo
festival on the Wii U this Friday
if you're into third person stealth
action games alkalines gun comes out on
the nights on current-gen consoles and
PC that's a full 24 hours ahead of all
the crazy finally rodea the sky soldier
which was released in Japan a couple
months back on 3ds and Wii U makes its
way to North America in Europe this week
so that's all the games coming out this
week in between fallout 4 Tomb Raider
and legacy of the void you have a lot of
options remember that release dates are
based on retailer listings and they're
subject to change see you next week